Yes. I want to if this is not easy to please. We will see. You know as her just. Own will sing into.
This country just to go out for a ride how did i come to name the prize.
Well back when the icarus hosts of was first happening.
Or even be fooled and actually used to come down he used to go down a bar and. So the nation.
Around broken hated being involved probably from the sixty's.
With the for the new age or the hippie movement as it was. And being somewhat very radical myself.
Looking for an alternative. In life and not being happy with the system with the rot. Of the system.
So they used to venture around going to different places and. Can actually remember.
I think the fistula was advertised quite a lot. And decided to come down and check it out of the group of friends.
I was living in prison at the time.
And living in a community house for me and all star houses a number of us living there.
And we all decided to come down and see what was happening so we came down before the festival. It was sort of.
Interesting. Getting out of it. So the smoking and tripping about it.
It's always good to get out in the country especially if you're tripping on acid as you sort of.
It's nice to get away from people and you can sort of. Be relaxed environment that you feel safe and settle it. So.
Get into nature. So that was a real buzz. Coming down here in his nice area. People seem friendly.
Interesting things going on. And then when the festival was happening. This was quoted as. Just. I suppose the people.
Thing. Apart from the area the land is i mean it's obviously unique. Obviously.
Is different this has a lot to offer the pros so i think the people at the time
when the first of those on it was very colorful. So if i remember it was sort of towards the end of.
When all the festivals were happening from the sixty's. Was when they started you know.
Dying out within this aquarius festival happened and. It was interesting it was it was cool.
By the whole town i suppose his holdall village being there only shops and things and. I will sit up there.
He sort of wander around and help yourself. Get out of it. So that you know the actual hills around at.
When the festival was on. Role was on a virtually directly around the town itself in the people were sort of.
Mingled around the hills and. Camped tents. All sorts of. Unique drawings will lower the temperature on this.
I suppose it was typical. For those the. Festivals around that time. Sort of love experimenting looking searching.
Sort of looking at. Concepts and new ideas. Sort of interacting with different people. Yeah. Hadas.
Highlights highlights. I suppose there was no warning. Syfy cool. Major one that i can think of this is that.
I suppose. The whole essence of the festival in the feeling of the area was. Yeah it's not us it's great you know.
Be nice to be able to live this way. And it's stimulating exciting. It's.
As cool as that after the fists were going back to.
The usual stuff and a half and full back into the system and the rotten.
And not feeling happy about it and then going back down to name been some months later the chicken had to get a good.
Sort of finding it.
Sort of changed it was even a different feeling amongst the people there's some sort of a reason for him to and.
I think it was to do with. You know like with with anything.
If something to actually happen it needs energy to go into it. So i need the energy comes from. And if.
If we're not putting the energy into it. And it's not really happening and. You sort of get people that.
They just appear to go just purely for what they can get out of it and don't put anything into it.
And of course it doesn't work. You get too many people doing that which is the thing start getting resentment.
From other people. Because it's not enhancing is not adding to the whole thing is just taking from.
I think that's why a particular feeling. Of the place and as you know this is suspicion rolls. You know. If you know.
You know what do you want you know what are you doing here you know. What do you want from us. So the thing. Is it was.
Yeah. Yeah. That was a few months. And then i think probably a year. A year and a half after the fist and back and.
That feeling was still strongly there. I suppose also the other thing of.
When the actual communities or communes as they were they were forming and. Co-produce. The.
Just wondering how safe would actually be and if would work and trying to break away from my. Feelings.
Conditionings of security in the system. Breaking away from.
You know these false since it's the security you know having a job and having money and having a car and a house
and you go build a structure around you that you can hide in support you. And all your friends there.
I suppose his friends. And. Sort of breaking away from that and this. I found it was actually very difficult.
Coming to a place where it's sort of it is a different creation then.
Even though it's stimulating exciting they still iffy effect i think as with now.
Well i survive in this sort of life we get out of a life or lose whatever it is.
I already have you consciously pull you know so through that you must challenge. This. Yeah i think.
I've a funny myself and probably also i know. I have these two s. Pigs. In the us. And they go we all do.
A lot of people do we have many different aspects. Whenever he's.
This is to be these two major arrests pick someone is that. I can fit into the system quite easily in play to get.
And it's. Because it's easy to do. You know you can just fall into it if you know you just become like a clown.
Even though. It was easy to do that and to be that. This is others. S. Picture of me that is very radical.
And it sort of says you know i need to be looked at i need to be expressed you know this isn't the philly. Me.
By doing this and. So i find when i look.
Look at that aspect of myself that it wants to challenge all this it doesn't want to play that i will lease.
Rules that. That would create a personal analysis is that the really. I just i don't know i just. Challenge origin.
It wasn't a feeling in me. So. Sort of realizing that this is s. Picked on me that i need to fill.
Like his federal psych i was all. All those pretty terms with oneself and lost all sexuality. The whole long.
These guys. Was. This question. Just recently i find it. Just. He was a creationist. How were they fulfilled.
I don't think they are. If so. I don't really know if my experience. Expectations had been fulfilled.
Because i find i'm still questioning things. I still looking at myself. And what's. Reflecting back around me.
I suppose i wonder if that's just an ongoing thing. And we'd likely how we create things around is and.
We caught up in our own creations and the mold we put into it peaches is gone and they really need to drop all the.
Just recently. I've been looking at how i feel and with where i am now and here i'm feeling clues.
And after being here for ten days. And has developed. And i find it are looking more into my soul to us to.
Maybe looking at things like. Once and selfishness and what we need out of life will feel we need to have a life.
Well what i'm actually doing. In my life is to where i'm putting my energies.
And maybe part of that is still creating what what i was trying to get away from the full
and bring it all here with me and creating it again. A whether it's will actually hear anyone. Sold and.
Within ones that are you afraid it. Is. Isolation.
If you want to give it to the query system or thing because that was some time back going back twenty years ago.
And then there was a period or probably ten years before i actually started living here in this area.
And eventually when i made that break came here. I looked at this place. Was this a cattle property thinking.
On the surface it didn't look very good its looked like paddick. But the.
Feeling of the leaves there's the feeling some feeling of it and. That's when i clicked into this where i live and. So.
I decided to buy. Moving here finally breaking over. In the system and moving here.
Then interacting with the land of the peoples. At that particular stage and going through cool.
Major court case which went for eight months in the kitty. So the like of amenities and. No proper roads.
It rained for nearly eight months. Churkin that's what i considered.
Even though at times it was very tasty you think shit. But i wanted to take.
What's had the court cases and that crazy thing.
I came here to get away from all that stuff and it's all here if i'm also confronted bought it. But then.
The realisation in that is that. I suppose. Like trying to avoid something or running away from something.
You further cool. The you gotta. You have to confront it and go through.
So also while that was happening in interacting with the land. And that. That was really great in the rain it was cool.
It was the land it was. Digging holes plenty trees. So we could do it on yeah. It was cool cool.
Even the whole pioneering spirit of and the other people sort of moved in. Sort of.
She's funny i had always those people are like it's the old to energies. Tends to attract people to is this.
Supposed light in the they sort of. Want to get away from a system that tends to just clone people. Stereo time.
In that diversity. You can find that point you know.
People can be can think totally different two you can have totally different purpose. Perception of.
Live when it comes to consensus of agreeing that. It is if it's not there. But the other aspect of that is that.
You can learn a lot. When you start interacting with people in these different kostis different ninety's.
Thing a whole lot. And it's interesting. So then getting on with a few years after being.
So really starting to develop in getting into the land and going through different stages of life. Meditating and.
Getting into working meditations. Of seeing people for weeks on end. And great really cool.
Getting into the feeling of the land and. The the vibe of the n.h.
We all whatever it is what if you want to call it real. It was brilliant.
I think those particular to all of that particular time was. Was really pretty good. When i reflect back on it.
It was good because the solitude the feeling of a drug. I get up in the morning and just spend the whole day.
Working in the garden and staying there until the sun went down.
And even if it was rainy days to get out there and good.
And it was a lick it was really would get was it was an enjoy it really. More.
Good just getting out there and just working in the god. But it wasn't really luke. It was. It was an enjoyment it was.
I'd like to say it was a meditation and all of a sudden building in iraq was a kind interlocks. And i started to leave.
And i really enjoyed that. Because just by handling the rocks picking him up.
They you know they had different sizes different take she's feeling about it and and. The weight of the rocks and.
Also there is a feeling like an energy you get from the rocks and. This is an amazing experience.
This is free and i really light and building the wall as this goes when you see i'm finished with it
and you stop being creative with it and. Putting patterns in the walls and stuff. It's just nice. Credos great.
I think getting into a building at us. You can see the houses. In the beginning i used to think i was kidding myself.
Is to tell people he's going to build a house. I used to wonder about things which he had like and build a house on.
But difficult health food for their folly getting to a point where.
I sort of you know really have to do it had to do that so i did and. As foes with my particular nature.
Bring a different. Manic approach of behavior and sort of. Tend to be more into. The tally. You know sort of.
Making things out of so that. The. They looking for sayas. Because it is a word for to. I suppose being particular and.
Going through that experience for a couple is doing it for myself because i wanted to sort of challenge original.
Challenge it was some sort of thing whatever.
With that power tools all by hand and it was a hell of a lot of wood a lot of energy.
And i was used to really stress myself out at times.
Doing it really frustrated because of the hitting in the aisle
and sort of miss it which is almost something which is you know you get really aggro invalidly throw that amor over the
roof or the early pistol for the. Jump up and down and what it is and risk the day looking for the hannah. To.
I suppose that had a sensory war to her and maybe. I wonder that. Things we do that we don't realize will we.
You know that you get satisfaction that it was sense of achievement or whatever.
I think
when you do something that someone does your pat on the back that in some way that enhances you to to make you feel
good about it and that it was great and people say you know he is good
and then i think i hear that silver now i look at it
and i think give us a house after he says they had to really think of it that i would feel that you know it was my
sweat and blood that went into it and i had painted for it i was sort of forgotten. Or don't want to remember all that.
I think it is now. But i don't know whether i do it again. If i did i'd do it differently.
I wouldn't do it the same for use power tools. It's part of hating generators. As for that.
What's going on with the war. We a lot of his he called them. The next stage of. Of a growth of development.
Is this a good word to use i think growth is better. Of the village of bill and bill includes.
And it is a village to village. With the commercial center of life. And i can see that.
Yes great be good to have a commercial center down there. Have really santas. Commercials and a village. Santa.
So to life the heart of the village and us are that just remind of each is it. And this fictive being in a community.
And even though it's not a commune it's a community. Just like. Villages that are community.
Because something about this one parcel of land or whatever disease.
That it is i'm finding there is like an extended family. And even.
Even if there's people here that you mind if a tool to. He still had the sense of. Finding his place.
I think this is sort of interesting it's clear it's got a lot of good aspects to it. Sometimes you know. He said.
This is the. I suppose it's the yeah. I suppose you do and i think maybe it's something he sort of take for granted.
Decisions and recently. I've been looking at what i'm doing here and what i'm getting out of this place and.
Is it just. What are we creating his she's of the view of over again.
Because i can see that he has some food for you if you kill a family stuff.
You go to parties and it all revolves around the family structure. Has johnny going at school and.
You know winds of the school. Fight is on all that sort of stuff and. To me i find it just is.
I suppose there's no diff than that for me really. And especially for my radical son.
And i think this is really where a lot of the this is really a lot of why aren't they looking at that if you will ok.
If that's not what i want what i do something about it with radicals. Side. Already expressing that.
To see what happens will you have be honest with that that i speak to listen. And by doing that. Finding that.
The reaction coming back. Is. Yeah why not do it. Give it to them.
There are other people other and she said that a similar one. The same thing and. Feel the need for that too. So.
Ok i start doing that and. If that draws other energies other people to feel the same.
Then why don't you know what i have done. I suppose for. Three.
Bring out already close to what are called radical these new concepts of the way we live.
Rather than how we've brought off of conditions. To feel we should. We should live life.
In this new killer family thing the. The marriage thing that the mild female of one to one. A lot sort of stuff.
That possibly. I think there's very few people that could really get heated will find themselves and. That's with her.
That. This one thing even mild a female. Thing that i think very few people like shirley find that totally fulfilling.
But they tend to just go along with it if we close that's why it is.
And they say they don't question their role and say they find they can't or they don't want to.
And that possibly oh i feel that they live.
It so it's all interaction will possibly just for the detainees interaction. And that.
We're restricting as cells in a one to one relationship that we know a leveling ourselves to to interact
or to experience for life. And things like how we interact with people here. If you go to a social.
These limitations a little. Even if you may want to feel that you want it here to that person will they much to you.
He's too restrictive for these limitations. So you play along with it.
And then coming away from that situation i think it can be done that already for him. You know you.
He just not feeling something in yourself
and i think it's a spiritual aspect if you saw of myself that you're talking about myself. Maybe i find it.
Not for filling in most virtuous bit. Of the issues related to the injury i.
Being get a first person myself relating to me. To my own gayness maybe yes. I suppose a g.'s. But i do.
I think even if a person that was so cool straighter hitcher sexual. I think that same thing leads to the pine.
Sexuality i think. We were all just a sexual with it with homosexuals. Bisexual or heterosexual this was categorizing.
It's a life away. And sure you need to use those words for expression. But the realisation of where is that is just.
Individuality. It's just individuals. I sexual and.
I suppose for myself in and have to question my own sexuality and with the sisterhood growing up in a system that.
Conditions us that.
Heterosexuality is how it should be and that homosexuality is bad or wrong or evil or something like that.
I suppose that in itself. Has made me question because i have a feeling toward something.
And then a system that's telling me that you can't do that or you shouldn't do that. It contradicts.
So it's something i had to look at in myself and come to terms with it
and i suppose by that is accepting my own sexuality. But and with that. I mean except as a sexuality.
And then you can either. Fit it into a particular sector of the system like the you know.
The gay ghetto the gay movement of. You know whether it be the men's movement or.
If you are a woman with a lens or you don't have to be alone with the women's movement or whatever.
Whether it's a capitalism. Of socialism or whatever. This is where you want to fit in to a life. And.
I suppose coming here. Of evil is so. Because of life for myself in my view. Will my spiritual less pay.
To live a feeling in the world of film or digital life rather than just following a routine. The system.
I suppose was and stimulating when i was full was a rush. I think it's a hard life. What. What is my spiritual aspect.
I could say something valid that i could change on that. Next that. But i'm trying to find it. I suppose.
Feeling of the long range of racial harmony and. I suppose some positive esp a love that i consider love is possible.
And even as for those that they could if i speak to life which would come into the ages.
So i think it's a question of them. Using would see you. I don't see you could just say.
You can put your actual feelings this fishery your fuel your spiritual aspect of. Feelings into words.
She said possible. It's ten hundred pages. I just find it hard as for those. I suppose is a harmonious feeling.
And that includes everything. Positive nature to the. Yeah it'll feel like i feel a whole more harmonious.
With these trees around this greenery you haven't got a. I had a concrete jungle where it's still corners and angles.
You know you. You. You have a system where you've got to follow this particular line.
If you go down the road you can go for you could of had come for you. You could a follower. A rigid a rigid colds.
Yeah there. And i think in that heat. I find in myself that it was the stopping of a lot of mine.
And how i feel it should or should be the. You notice a slight flaw or this is this. Put it this way it is flow us but.
Yeah ride. Being gay and being here in this place. And bill includes. So who's coming here and.
Moving from queensland where at the time. It was still illegal to be caylee you know the little is.
Was still against homosexuality. For and even though i had sort of already confront of my sexuality.